I want to turn to the war between Israel
and Hamas in Gaza what is your view of
this War I think when you call it a war
you're doing a disservice to the people
who are having their limbs blown off by
some of the most advanced technical
Weaponry on the planet it is a genocide
and it is disgusting and it doesn't
matter which side of the political
Spectrum you fall on When You observe a
genocide in front of your very eyes you
should be disgusted which side is waging
genocide the Israelis are genociding the
Palestinians and know it as well as
everybody else does well then it seems
like your bosses are not allowing you to
know it what do you think of of what
Hamas did on October the 7th why are you
starting the story in the middle I just
asked you about the wider War I'm now
asking I can't Prof I cannot
professionally answer that question
without talking about the context that
led up to October 7th well nothing to my
mind justifies what happened October the
7th nothing justifies what happened
before October the 7th appears this the
exact point so you're talking to a man I
don't know what answer you expect from
me cuz let's forget the fact I'm a
Muslim you're talking to a man who is
fighting oppression to the best of his
ability because he believes that the
people in charge of the world are
enslaving us all to the point where I
detriment my own life I end up in a jail
cell because I'm speaking against
oppression then you're asking me what I
would do if my family was BL to pie
you're not in a jail hang you're asking
me what I would do if another government
came along and blew my family to pieces
you weren't put in a jail cell because
of Any oppression absolutely I was no
you weren't of course you were put in
jail C because you've been accused of
serious sexual crime I would not have
been accused if I was not monumentally
successful in speaking the truth let me
ask you again it's a simple question
some people can answer it straight away
including Pro Palestinians people I've
had on my program many are very quick to
say absolutely do you believe Hamas are
a terror organization and that's a very
interesting question but I think you're
pedaling Asin nities we just answer the
question can somebody do me a favor
Google Asin nities and find out if it's
a I know it means if it's not make sure
it's added to Webster on top G's orders
just are they a terror group you're
pedling Asin nities because I'll tell
you why Piers let me answer the question
of course you are simple question that's
like me asking I tell you why I asked
because the UK where you were born
prescribes Hamas as a terror they also
prescribe me as dangerous to children in
schools let me explain something to you
Pi if I were to sit here and say is
stealing wrong and you'd say yes and I
go ah but what if the person stealing is
trying to feed their family and and they
don't their family are going to die is
it still wrong you're trying to take a
very nuanced and complicated argument
and reduce it down to one sentence which
is failure you're trying to equate
stealing with a mob of terrorists
breaking over a border going to Peaceful
is that what Israel did minute a m of
terrorist over a and killing people is
that isra did going through a border on
October the 7th oh October the 7th
massacring young people at a festival
massacring families in their homes in a
k setting fire to them cutting their
heads off killing babies Oh killing
babies that was true well fine were the
babies vaccinated why are you being
flippant I'm not being flipping the
point I am making F no but the point I
am making is that the media lies firstly
secondly ask you we can ask I can ask
you about different things at the same
time right so I'm asking you first of
all specifically what is your reaction
to what happened in October the 7th sure
I'll answer the question professionally
I do not condone the loss of human life
on either side I think anybody doing
anything which directly damages
civilians is disgusting and abhorent
however I would be an amateur if I could
not sit and pretend I do not understand
the motivations behind either side this
is not even me taking a side I
understand why Israel is doing what is
doing I understand why Palestine is
doing what it's doing however I still
call the Israeli actions absolutely
abhorent and genocide okay we're going
to come to Israel's actions I promise
you we will ask that question
specifically but in terms of what Hamas
did on October the 7th do you accept
that was an act to terrorism it's an
interesting question because once not
really it is straight because you're the
person who would have called Nelson
Mandela a terrorist while he was still
in jail and one person's terrorist is
another person's Freedom fire for me to
answer the question yes you would have
for for me to answer the question I have
to be very professional Pierce for me to
sit on the outside in Romania with no
personal involvement in Israel Palestine
it's easy for me to say yes it was an
act of Terror however if I was in Gaza
if I was in an open air prison if my
family had been annihilated by bombs
from the sky if everybody I knew had
suffered the loss of a loved one if I
had no chance of any kind of Freedom or
democracy or standard of life would I
believe it was an act of Terror or would
I believe it's an act of resistance
against oppression you have to be very
careful how you answer these question
I think I understand what happens when
you take people and put them in such an
inhumane condition anybody to sit and
say that you're going to take people and
put them in absolutely inhumane
conditions and give them no standard of
life and they're not allowed to ever
fight back or they are ter anyone who
does that is an amateur I can agree with
you that the plight of the Palestinians
for many decades has been absolutely
shameful so what did we think was going
to happen Pierce no nothing justifies
what happened on October 7th are they do
nothing so what are they supposed to do
that was an act of medieval barbaric
terrorism nothing justifies did they
suffer of mediev they Medi bar did they
suffer acts of medieval barbaric
terrorism before that date yes and it's
unfortunately an eye for an eye in this
world I'm not condoning I'm being a
professional and answering to give me
one give me one example of where Israel
without any provocation went into what
no wait a specific question went into
Gaza and massacred 1500 innocent people
cutting their heads off taping and
boasting about what they' done back to
their families in Israel kidnapping
Holocaust Survivors bringing they
wouldn't have course done that in there
kidnapping old grandmothers and bringing
them back to Israel kidnapping babies
kidnapping children when is Israel
actually gone in and done something of
the scale of October the 7th there's
literally endless examples of that give
me one in 2014 they were bombing
civilians you know what Pierce let me
tell you something I'm not talking about
I'm not talking about what they would
categorized as retaliation for rocket
stri strikes and there's an arguable
Point as there is for example I'm
vehemently against the expansion of the
settlements on the West Bank I think
there are legitimate questions about the
proportionality of Israel's response
here but in terms of what Hamas
perpetrated on October the 7th there is
no no no instance of Israel doing that
to the people of Gaza and you have to
accept that if you don't accept that
you're either deluded or you're
deliberately not wanting to say the
obvious which is that was an act of
terrorism because you're concerned about
upsetting people in Palestine is that is
that the case let me go back to my first
point when I said you're pedaling Asin
nities the reason I said that is because
to look at a situation no matter how
heinous and to ignore all of the context
and pretend that you do not understand
why said situation happened is nothing
justifies terrorism on that scale
nothing is as no it's not it's not about
justification let me tell you why it's
not about justification it's about
understanding the realities of the world
let me tell you the reality of the world
Hamas came to power in 2005
hamas's initial founding Charter made it
clear that they are for the eradication
of Israel and on October the 7th they
prove what that means is they will kill
every Jew they can get their hands on
they are an existential threat to people
in Israel and to Jewish people and that
is I'm afraid the purest personification
of a terror group I also think by doing
what they did as they have done since
2005 they weren't representing innocent
Palestinian people in Gaza are suffing
they knew yes but Hamas knew when they
did what they did that Israel would
respond the way they did and that
thousands of innocent Palestinians would
get killed they knew that and they still
did it so my question for you is why
can't you which is my position on this
is very straightforward what Hamas did
was an act of Terror an absolutely
despicable Act of Terror and should be
called exactly what it is and they are
now demonstrably a terrorist group that
is why they were rightly prescribed that
by the UK and America and other
countries and to try and pretend they're
not makes you sound like Jeremy Corbin I
can't give a worse insult to throw at
you right so I don't think me and Corb
agree on but I also think there are
legitimate questions to come about the
way Israel's responded we can come to
that but I just want to ask you one more
time is what Hamas did on October 7th an
act of terrorism I think pierce it is
pedaling Asin enties for you to pretend
that enslaving you sound like Jeremy
Corbin no let me answer the question 15
times he refused to answer the question
question you're now you're now about
three or four are they group or not
they're one team's freedom fighter and
they are deemed a terrorist group what
do you think I think that if you lock
people in an open air prison and steal
their land they're going to retaliate so
they're not a terror group I think
they're going to retaliate they're not a
terror group one team's terrorist is
talk about eight are they a terror group
and also another thing I want to make
clear to you P only Jeremy Corbin has
done this done what refused to answer
the question I think that what they are
doing is seemly deemed an act of Terror
by the people that the terror these
weasly words they're not weasly of
course the Israelis think they're a
terror group and of course some of
course the Palestinians think they're
Freedom Fighters it's stupid that you're
asking the question most of the
Civilized world thinks they're a terror
group Committed an act to terrorism it's
not difficult what they did was an act
of terrorism and I think that if Israel
continues to to conduct acts of
terrorism on the Palestinian people
they're going to do nothing but streng
the reaction I'm that's a different
conversation I'm about to have with you
about Israel's response but before I get
there one more time is Hamas a terror
group who committed an act of terrorism
I think that when you lock people in an
open air prison you're going to have
ration no because I have to there's
people who are firstly first things I
want to say you know mind me saying I
think it's spineless sure I do that's
fine you sound like Jeremy Corbin well
that that is an did you see my interview
with him no right 15 times last week I
asked him the same question 15 times he
prevaricated and wouldn't answer
eventually when someone does that enough
times you know what they really think
you don't think they're a ter let me
answer think they a terror group no what
I think is this on certain i' be really
curious what you think an act of Terror
is if it's not massacring 1500 innocent
people including Holocaust Survivors
kidnapping babies decapitating people
cutting their limbs off raping women
yeah talk about missing limbs we're
going to talk about that when we talk
about all done but when we get there
it'll be in the context of you not
admitting that was an act of ter well
let me answer the question for the final
time I am a realist and as a realist
sometimes you do not come to the
conclusion of labeling good guys and bad
guys the world is not black and white oh
Hass bad guys the world is not black and
white the world is actually very gray
anybody who sits and thinks there's
clearly a good guy clear a good guy and
clearly a bad guy does not understand
how the world works and as a realist
what you do is you look at scenarios and
you understand why they happen how
unfortunate they are how unfortunate the
loss of human life is how civilians die
on both sides how Innocents are dying in
a chess game played by the elites on
both sides both sides you have innocent
people who didn't even vote for the
person making the decisions who are
ensuring their death signing their death
warrants it's unfortunate on both sides
but listen
sir you would not Advocate Russia doing
any of the things to Ukraine that Israel
is doing to to to to Palestine you would
not see here Russia has been doing
exactly that Russia has not done a
fraction of ukra that Israel has Ria
Russia illegally invaded a sovereign
Democratic country and has committed a
barbaric Rampage trying to seize as much
of Ukraine as it can bombing maternity
hospitals killing innocent women
question like don't even try and have
some kind of no no this isation of this
I will a Hamas rocket a tiny Hamas
rocket that can make a pothole in the
road and then they get hit back with
cruise missiles let me ask you a
question Ukraine sent a drone and it hit
the Kremlin a drone attack it did
nothing it damaged some some shingles if
if Russia decided to then respond with a
missile attack on a hospital and
annihilate 800 people do you think that
would be allowed exactly what it has
been would you Advocate have you seen
would you support that have you seen the
state of marle level to the ground the
ukrainians did level the correct no the
Russians 2014 the Russian level Mar and
and my question to you is would you
Advocate those reactions let me ask you
another question P this a genuine
question let me ask you a question
because I want to understand your point
actually my interview of you yeah but
but you tried to understand mine I just
want to understand your point of view if
if I believed or if Israel believed that
one of the people in your house was a
terrorist and decided to destroy your
entire house and kill your entire family
would you sit and say well maybe there
was a terrorist inside I accept that or
would you be enraged genuine question I
don't think you can take an individual
person's response well it's a bunch of
individual people in Gaza they're people
individuals with thoughts and dreams and
aspirations which are being annihilated
15y old girls without legs to cruise
missiles they are individual people
they're not cattle to they're people
right and so with the people in Israel
October the and that's why it's so
heinous which is my exact point but not
heinous enough to reach your bar of
terrorism reach bar of terrorism no it's
understanding why things happen by not
saying it you've made your position
clear just as Jeremy Corbin did and to
pretend you're any different is
ridiculous let's move on to Israel's
response because there are legitimate
questions about this Hamas embeds itself
35 40,000 terrorists in my estimation
you can call them whatever you like um
and they're embedded amongst the
civilian population predominantly in
Northern Gaza they we know from
intelligence over the last 20 years
which you won't believe because the
Matrix has made it all up corre we know
from intelligence that historically
Hamas likes to embed itself particularly
around things like schools and hospitals
and mosques because that makes it more
difficult if uh the Israel's attack yeah
now Israel has killed nearly 12,000
people in its response right there are
many people around the world demanding a
ceasefire who think that is a
ridiculously disproportionate response
to what happened well it was genocide
they would want to kill everyone in
palestin they don't they just want to
drive them all out whereas Hamas do want
to kill every Jew that is actually what
genocide you know what's actually
interesting because you've spoken about
this subject of people more who actually
understand the conflict better than I do
Muhammad hij understands it better
lowkey understands it better I'm talking
from a very general humanistic
perspective because I don't understand
that absolute intricacies like they do
do you know what genocide means of
course I do right genocide means you
want to eradicate an entire People based
on racial ethnicity Israel clearly
doesn't want to do that to the
Palestinian people if he did he wouldn't
tell a million of them as it turned out
who Moved South now there are arguments
about whether to attack them as they
moved well some people got hit as they
moved oh some people got hit some people
got hit you know what you know what
happens you know what Andrew wait till
it's your son wait it's your son I agree
and you know what Andrew war is horrific
it's horrific the question is is it a
just War for Israel to go after Hamas
and if it is and you believe as I do
they Hamas has to be got rid of how do
you do that if you don't do it the way
Israel is is doing it how do you get rid
of that terror group now you agree with
anything they're doing because you can't
even categorize them as a terror group
no the reason I won't agree with them is
because I'm a human Pierce and please
let me answer this without being
interrupted you didn't answer my earlier
question for a reason because you knew
that you couldn't answer it without
proving my point the question about the
fact that if they decided to cruise
missile your house because they thought
somebody inside was a terrorist you
would not accept the loss of your family
that you have raised you would not
accept that okay absolutely so let me
answer this as a
professional what's funny is I'm a
humanist like I professional what by the
way a Prof the professional please let
me answer let me answer what are you at
you think profession and I'm talking
about this from a humanistic perspective
right and like I said you've talked
about you've talked to people more
knowledgeable than me on the details of
the subject listen to me very carefully
I thought we lived in a Democratic
Society you just said 35,000 Hamas
terrorists and this is the thing that's
most upsetting to me this would
genuinely upset to me Israel
intelligence will say a guy's a Hamas
terrorist has that guy gone to a court
of law has there been a democratic
process has he been proven to be a
terrorist no they've just decided from
their intelligence that couldn't see an
invasion coming from hundreds of of
miles away so this intelligence is it's
not it's not great so they've decided
this person might be in intelligence
without court case without any kind of
democratic process and because of that
they've decided to annihilate civilians
along with him and it's all just
collateral damage and nobody should care
that is not a humanistic perspective and
that is disgusting and any person in the
west who is advocating for that is a
hypocrite because if it was turned on
them if if the American government said
we think the person in your shopping
mall one of the people you were shopping
along side in the mall might have
committed a crime we didn't take them to
court we think they might have so we
killed your whole family get over it so
the last is a clown and a hypocrite so
the last time what do you expect full
grown men to do to respond what do you
expect full grown men to do when you
kill all of their families and leave
them locked in an open air respond the
last time that Jewish people fac an
existential threat was in World War II
and the Nazis who wanted to take over
the world and kill every Jewish person
the Nazis Al ultimately defeated by
Winston Churchill leading the allies and
Winston Churchill in the process of
defeating the Nazis killed a lot of
German innocent civilians in the process
do you think that was justified let me
ask a question was it well no I ask the
questions was it Justified sir I believe
and let me just get this right in my
head yeah think about it no I don't need
to think about your question I believe
that the Nazis which were obviously
heinous I'm not advocating anything they
do it's disgusting the Nazis I'm glad we
beat them I'm actually a huge Teran yeah
they were right so I believe that they
were so when you Massacre Jewish people
you're terrorists when except when you
do it in Israel when you try and conduct
genocide on a populist because you don't
want them on land you say is yours then
you are terrorist exactly what Hamas did
on October what Israel had did before
that so you've literally just described
what Hamas do you just describe what
Israel do they're trying to genocide the
Palestinians as we speak and this is the
exact point to sit no but to sit here
Israel a terrorist I think that what
they're doing now is disproportionate
and genocidal Terris it's genocidal so I
guess that makes it terrorism it's
genocidal they're terrorists for
responding to an act of Terror but the
people who committed the act of Terror
are not terrorist the way in which
they're responding you see the problem
in that argument no I really I pierce
what they are doing now slaughtering
1500 people in the way they did it is
not an act of Terror by terrorists but a
response from the people on the
receiving end rather like the response
of the Allies in World War II to what
the Nazis did that apparently is the
only Act of terrorism you say 12,000
people the Israelis have killed thus far
yes I saw a video of a 15-year-old girl
with no legs begging to die yeah she was
begging to die saying I have no future
cuz my parents are gone or my legs are
gone no future no but you say that right
you talk about numbers and statistics
and you say a few people got caught you
don't think of gazin and you don't think
of as Muslims and Palestinians as
individual people oh yes I do no you
don't because if you did if you did if
you did you won't be happy with What's
happen say that about me well okay then
don't put them together in numbers not
numbers I've spoken for many years about
apply to the Palestinian people I think
it's outrageous that Israel has any
control over their ability to function
with water with fuel with uh other
energy and so on food that's interesting
so if you were in Gaza as a gazan male
of masculine fighting age and you
believe the things you currently believe
what would you do about it I'm just
asking you know what nothing justifies
the terrorism never you'd be a terrorist
I'm asking what you do no no I
understand why people in Palestine feel
oppressed understand why they want
freedom I understand why they want the
same rights as the people in Israel then
here's a perfect on that we agree abely
but nothing nothing justifies what
happened in October well here's where
here's where we disagree P because as a
professional when we both agree on the
point that the people inside of Gaza are
being oppressed and that their life is
being detriment and that they have no
way of getting out we as a professional
agree with I understand pressure cookers
explode you're pretending they shouldn't
you're saying that they should never
explode nothing bad should ever happen
should just be allowed to subjugate them
for Endless years and nothing happened
and I'm a realist to understand that
pressure cookers explode and that's what
happen we need a solution to the problem
or it will continue to happen you're not
a realist because actually you are not
accepting that what they did October the
7th was an act of terrorism by
terrorists you won't accept that you
think actually their freedom fights is
doing some kind of resistance and I say
that is ridiculous and shameful that's
the difference between this I understand
that pressure cookers explode PI right
so you think it's perfectly reasonable
what happened then I don't think it's
reasonable I think it's I think it's a
shame natural consequence I think it's a
shame a shame that's it I think I think
it's a shame that we're living in the
world now where people are reduced to
basically suicide to try and fight for
freedom for their families if they have
one left because they all committed
suicide those men who did that they
didn't have they didn't have a chance of
survival I think when you because that's
because they believe that they're
marching themselves are going to better
you oppress people to the point where
their family is dead and they have
nothing to live for I think that's a
shame so you do you support Islamic
fundamentalism absolutely not H you
support an islamist ideology absolutely
not right what I support so why do you
support a m i support Justice in the UN
Hamas I support Justice in the universe
you support Hamas no you don't well I
don't know the ins and outs of hamas's
creed I have to be very honest you know
what they did in October the 7th you
support them I understand why that
happened and I'm saying it's a shame but
you won't denounce them I say it's a
shame will you condemn them I'm I I
can't sit here and condemn the obvious
outcome of of consequence wow really how
can I condemn you can't condemn herass
for what they did well we know what's
going to happen and we need a solution
you're very quick to condemn Israel's
response but you won't condemn the
terror attack which prompted it no I'll
tell you why even though Hamas Knew by
doing what they were doing that would be
the response do you think they knew that
of course they knew that you think they
knew that Israel they did it quite
deliberately you know why because they
were funded and supported by Iran they
didn't like the fact that Israel was
normalizing relations with a bunch of
Arab countries from the UAE to Bahrain
to Morocco and then coming down the line
was going to be Saudi Arabia that was a
threat to the Iran view of what should
be happening in that region Iran are the
ones who support and fund and arm Hamas
and they uh clearly in my estimation Al
it hasn't been probably established yet
but clearly Hamas couldn't have done
this on their own they've done it with
support from Iran and they've gone and
committed an act of such heinous
atrocity that they knew what the
response would be and that means that
they sentenced in that moment not just
1500 people in Israel to death in the
most appalling manner possible but they
also sentenced to death thousands and
thousands of innocent Palestinians
including many innocent children because
half the population had children and
Hamas knew that was what was going to
happen so my question is how can anyone
think that Hamas is a Force for good the
palan are I said they're un no I didn't
say they're are Force for good I said
it's a pressure cooker and it's a shame
you even let me ask let me ask the
question do you think if we gave the
Palestinian people basic human rights
that Hamas would find it more difficult
to recruit new
soldiers uh I yeah I probably probably
if we treat them like humans this won't
happen so we agree and let's move on I
think there's a real danger in the scale
of Israel's response that you radicalize
a whole new generation of Palestinians I
think that's a real danger by the way
I've said that we can agree on that so
perhaps it was Israel's actions before
October 7th that radicalized the
soldiers who invaded so you agree with
me so let's move no I don't no nothing
justifies nothing justifies what they
did let me ask you about the reaction
that you've had from uh certain people
who I think at one stage uh you had
a good relationship with sure one is um
Jordan Peterson and the other one Ben
Shapiro let's talk about Jordan first
sure you've had a bit of a to and fro
with him but what is your view of him I
think Jordan and I actually agree on
many issues I think the enemy of my
enemy is my friend I think we have a lot
more in common than we have that we
disagree on we have different views of
the world on certain things I think we
approach them from different places he's
far more in his mind whereas i' been
more in a Physical Realm than he does I
have nothing against Jordan I don't
dislike him I do find it and I must be
honest a bit disingenuous and
hypocritical that he speaks mental
strength and then ends up addicted to an
anti-depressant I don't think he should
ever take anti-depressants ever I've
been through worse than what he's been
through and I didn't take a single drug
however I have nothing against the guy
he says very intelligent things and I'd
be interested to argue with him or
discuss or debate with him but I think
we'd actually agree on most points to be
honest with you I don't think we I mean
he may be unhappy with somehow how I've
lived my life and some things I've done
but we've already discussed the fact
that I come from the lowest income area
of the UK and most people around me were
selling drugs so at least I didn't do
that so I'm not going to allow somebody
who's a professor at a university who's
had an easy life come along and tell me
how people from the streets should
survive you have to find a way out SK
Richard D trying but I have nothing
against the guy I just think that he's
been a bit hypocritical and then
truthfully the only time I've been
genuinely a bit appalled by any of his
actions was the Tweet he made on Israel
Palestine when he said give them hell I
know that's an easy thing to say and
it's an expression that people use and
they throw it around flippantly but but
I think when you actually wish hell upon
other human beings I think it's a
disgusting thing to do because hell is
that 15-year-old girl with no legs and
her parents were dead when you see her
crying her eyes out begging to die that
is hell and I don't think you should
genuinely wish hell on anyone Israel or
Palestinian either anyone I'm a humanist
I don't want anybody to die and when he
was wishing hell on an entire population
he did Express regret for the way he
phrased and he should because it's
disgusting I've not wished hell on the
Israelis I've not wished hell on the
isra State I don't want any Israeli
civilian to go through with that
15-year-old Palestinian girl's going
through not a single one he said about
you Jordan peton I'm not particularly
happy to be grouped with Andrew Tate I
think there are some elements about what
he does that are quite
reprehensible I'm sure he has I'm not I
don't know everything he says and he may
disagree with some of my points of view
as I said I have nothing against him I
don't think anything he says is
particularly wrong I think that he's
hypocritical because of the
anti-depressant problem and I think that
the fact he wishes hell on other humans
because he gets emotionally involved in
a conflict which within two minutes of
it's sparking off he's wishing genocide
I think that says a lot about his
personality but overall when he speaks
at length a lot of the things he says
are pretty well thought through and
pretty constructive I have nothing
against the guy let me turn to Ben
Shapiro he said let me assure you as
someone has not pimped women and bragged
about it the morality requires that
those who rope women and kidnap women
must be eradicated not negotiated with
he says on my show I won't be lectured
on morality and toughness by Andrew Tate
his great idea of toughness and morality
is pimping women and dring about it on
air and then trying to quasy walk it
back while simultaneously maintaining
many of the same positions and flexing
his biceps listen everyone should be
able to tweet whatever it is they want
I'm more for an open discourse even with
people who I think are dead wrong on a
lot of issues but Andrew Tate is dead
wrong on a lot of these issues and the
particularly ridiculous posturing about
being a yes you're very tough when you
want people to make peace with
terrorists who just murdered their
children very very tough what do you say
to that so Ben is a warmonger Ben has
been wrong on basically every single
issue you can name he was with you with
the vaccine and and every other War Ben
is always calling for other people's
young men to go and die in some War he
seems to love it I don't know if he has
short man syndrome but he's always
behind his desk calling about how
important it is that big strong men like
me go and die and the reason he tweeted
that and said that is because when Hamas
and Israel the very early in the
conflict I think it was three days in
were discussing possible peace talks he
tweeted no absolutely not [__] them kill
them all and I said I said Ben as a man
who's done his own fighting because I've
had a life of pain and violence listen
to me peace is always worth a
conversation what I said is that we
should always be prepared to at least
discuss peace he because he's a war
Monger said no peace is not worth a
conversation you're this you're that da
because he's always sitting behind his
desk he must have a booster chair and
he's always running his mouth trying to
invoke violence and call for war and I
find it kind of hypocritical because a
man who's so small he would dive he was
slapped on the street sitting behind a
desk and screaming for other people to
be annihilated I think is kind of it's
worse than actually think I believe
insane I believe if he was sitting here
listening to this he would say that what
he's screaming for is for Jewish people
in Israel be to defend themselves and he
a jewi does is call for war and I agree
defending yourself that's all he does
that's all he does and calling for war
and call and defending yourself is very
different than genocide and Ben like I
said overall most of Ben's worldviews
and mine probably align we don't align
on the religious sect don't rely on the
religious points fine but our overall
worldviews of a house of should function
probably align on many of the key issues
I'm not I don't have a beef with Ben and
I don't watch his show and I have no
idea what he talks about a lot of the
time but what I do know is every time I
turn it on he's calling for someone
else's son to go and die in a ditch
somewhere for his interests and I don't
like people who are not advocates for
peace blessed are the peacemakers said
Candace who is far more intelligent than
Ben will ever be and she is completely
right he replied that rhetoric starting
an argument with me when I said we
should talk about peace I say we should
talk about peace he calls for the death
of civilians and somehow we're asking
why my point of view is seen as abstract
it's insane why can't we all just sit
down and say the fighting must end why
can't we do that why can't we sit and
say nobody should be dying let's stop
using the most advanced military
weaponry on the planet to blow the limbs
off children why can't we say that
without being deemed some kind of
terrorist sympathizer or anti-semite
it's Insanity Trump came along and
didn't start a single War he's the only
one who didn't and they're going to come
along him and make him a bad guy when a
new president comes in it's just endless
war and death and killing have you seen
a dead body Pierce have you seen people
lose a [__] limb it's disgusting I
know what's happening over there have
you seen I don't need to tell you about
the parts of my history that I'm not
prepared to share Pierce me I said it to
bed I said people who have done their
own fighting and seen their own violence
and have seen people bleed out in the
street from a stab wound are not going
to be so so smart and so quick to sit
behind a desk and call for the death of
innocent people it's just disgusting
what's happening I don't want anyone to
die on either side and when I come along
as a peacemaker and say this is insane
because he's a warmonger because he has
chosen blinkers and sees one side of the
argument and refuses to accept the
humanity of Palestinians he says I'm a
bad person for calling for peace you
know why because he'll probably listen
to this interview and say this guy can't
even describe her mass as
terrorist if Ben Shapiro thinks bad of
and if you don't think what happen to
the people in Israel October 7th is an
act of terrorism did I not just say I
want all people you are just you are
just as partisan to one side as you
believe Ben Shapiro did I not just say I
want all people to start dying stop
dying Pierce don't interrupt this it's
two sentences I want all people to stop
dying however I understand what is going
to happen when you create a pressure
cooker that is my that is my answer and
it's extremely professional I don't want
anyone to die and because I don't want
anyone to die because I'm a peacemaker
because I'm a humanist I understand you
cannot lock people in an open air prison
for an un determined a m period of time
without provoking terrorism so out of
Interest what would you have done if
you'd been Israel after October the 7th
that's a really interesting question and
I think there's people who are more
qualified than me to answer given the
Hamas last week said we're going to try
and do the same thing again and again
and again what would you do to defend
the people of Israel good question they
have the Iron Dome which is largely
effective I think that their border
security is usually effective it's very
interesting that it wasn't on this so
you would say they would do nothing
other than tighten up security I think
if I was truthfully I'll answer the
question if I was truthfully in charge
of Israel I would have found out how our
border was penetrated I would have made
sure that was impossible to do I would
have had large con conversations and
discourse during that period which would
probably take weeks to ensure that my
border was impenetrable because we were
at no genuine threat of a repeat attack
and then I would make it clear that
there will be some repercussion
unless unless there would be some
repercussion unless we can come to peace
terms I don't think theas doesn't want
peace of course not but I'm saying
that's St position of course of course
be ask what I do I would have found out
first things first I'm a man so first
things first you fix the problem okay
our bord has been penetrated how do we
make sure that doesn't happen again how
did it happen internal investigation
let's make sure the border is secure now
our civilians are safe our civilians are
safe which buys us time let's have a
conversation and see if we can actually
reason with a Mas if we can't then there
might be a there might be some military
intervention but there certainly
wouldn't be bombing hospitals Cruise
missling refugee camps there wouldn't be
any of the things is going on now
absolutely you wouldn't try to attack
the people no because this is a rushed
and emotional response and that's what I
would prevented I would have made sure
as a man I didn't make a rush in
emotional response you'd be more like
Neville Chamberlain trying to do peace
with the Nazis and Winston church or
trying to kill them well yeah that's an
interesting question you're an AO not a
warrior well I still think I'm a warrior
but I think that when you're a warrior
you have to be very capable and that's
what Neville Chamberlain's view was we
we should do peace with the N you have
to be very understanding of your power
and you have to use it responsibil
responsibly and just like I said earlier
when I'm trying to be responsible about
what I say to the young men of the world
I would understand as Israel I must be
responsible with my massive military
might to make sure I don't kill
civilians and I would sit and try and
make a measured response and I'd be a
professional and I would consider them
human beings and I would secure my
border and try and come up with a plan
better than oh no I'm mad I'm emotional
now let's go kill everyone I think
that's the wrong response correct I
don't think I don't think that's the
right thing to do we've spent a long
time talking um you're going to find out
at some stage today or in the next few
days whether you're going to get your
possessions back happen or not happen
but then there's likely to be a trial
and that will determine how you spend
the next 10 years of your life almost
certainly which is a sobering thought
for anyone yeah when you look back on
the whole Arc of the last few years you
know you've expressed some regret
because of you're turning to Islam
you're changing in your philosophy from
a religious perspective you've
acknowledged that some of the stuff you
used to do was
immoral do you look at the journey
you've gone on here and think that in a
way not withstanding the Matrix and
everything else that maybe you yourself
could have done things differently to
avoid being in this position absolutely
I'm a man and I take absolute
self-accountability you have to as a man
your superpower is looking in the mirror
and understanding everything that
happens to you both good and bad to a
degree is your fault it could have all
been influenced I could have avoided all
of this I could have avoided The Matrix
attacks or sorry I could have avoided
jail cell if you don't let me using that
term I could have avoided all the
negative press I could have chosen to
work in Starbucks and just stayed to
nobody I made choices that put me in
this position I take responsibility for
them I said things on the internet in a
satirical way on videos that got 110
views when YouTube was brand new that I
did not expect to become the most viral
videos in the world because I didn't
expect to become the most famous and
known person on the planet that's all
true I'm not saying I have no part to
play in any of this however I can still
say that I'm completely innocent I can
still say that is only my fame and
notoriety that has inspired the
prosecution service to try and even put
me in jail in the first place I can
still say that there's some unfair
policing in the world depending on your
political views I can still say all of
those things while accepting absolute
responsibility for the situation I am in
Andrew Tate thank you very much thank
you
sir